- It's also millions
and millions of people.
Not only millions
of people in Israel,
millions of Jews
throughout the world,
but millions of non-Jews who
see in the story of Israel
a parable for humanity.
Because if the Jewish people
can overcome the most
dreadful odds in history,
can come back from the dead,
can ford this river between
annihilation and salvation
and build this remarkable state,
then there's hope
for all of humanity.
(calm music)
- I am Dave Rubin,
and joining me today
is the twice and
future prime minister
of the state of Israel
and author of the new
book, "Bibi: My Story".
Prime Minister
Benjamin Netanyahu,
Welcome to "The Rubin Report".
- Good to be with you. Pleased.
- You know, I have to say,
I've watched you
obviously on television,
a million interviews
over the years,
speaking at the UN,
all kinds of things,
and one of the things
that I always think
when you are speaking or
any advocate for Israel,
is why don't they
show more maps?
Just show a map of the Middle
East and the size of Israel
verse, you know, the entire
region and everything else.
And then I get a
copy of your book,
and we're gonna show you
the full thing on screen,
but I'm gonna hold it
up for just a moment.
That's exactly how the
book begins, right?
The opening flap right there,
just to give a little
context to the size.
And I thought that would
be an interesting way
to start the conversation.
- Wait a minute, wait a minute.
You have to do something.
Open that book.
- Yes.
- Put your thumb,
put your finger on Israel
so they get a feeling
for the Arab world.
This is Israel, right?
- Yes, exactly.
- And don't even begin to
encompass the Arab world or Iran
in these two flaps, so
that's my two cents' worth
of the proportion.
- Yeah, well, I thought it
was a nice way to start,
because basically
when people look
at most maps of the world,
you can't even fit one letter
of the word Israel
on Israel itself.
And I feel like if
people understood that
a little bit more,
maybe they'd be perhaps
a little bit kinder,
is that just naivete as someone
that's been defending Israel
for 60 plus years?
- Well, it's wishful
thinking, but yeah.
I guess when people are
exposed to the facts,
which many are not, yeah,
they see it differently,
and they realize that
Israel is a tiny country,
but it's a gigantic country.
Because even though we
constitute less than one 10th,
one 10th of 1% of the
world's population,
we have been consistently ranked
in the decade that I led the
country between 2010 and 2020
as the eighth most powerful
country in the world,
which is kind of unbelievable,
I mean, when you think of it.
And that is, I
suppose, not only,
you can explain that rationally,
but I think it's a miracle
of faith and resolution.
Israel, because
of the resolution,
the resolve of its citizens,
the genius of its people
has become the juggernaut
innovation nation in the world.
We've just crossed in GDP,
we've crossed Japan,
France, Britain,
and Germany, GDP per capita.
And remember, I describe
this in my book,
when we began the
economic revolution
towards free markets,
away from socialism,
we were basically the last
place in Western Europe,
and now we're pretty
much in first place,
and we're gonna catch up
with the United States.
That's a personal quest.
I'm not saying that we'll
beat the United States,
but we'll catch up
with the United States.
- So as I described
in the opening,
you are the twice and future
prime minister of Israel.
As we speak right now,
you're in the midst
of forming this coalition.
You have the mandate to do it.
You've done this a
couple times before,
but Israel seems to
have elections every,
what, six months or so.
Are you confident
that you're gonna pull
this thing together?
I mean, this one looks
a little more solid,
I guess, than the
last few, right?
- Yeah, well we had...
First of all, this
is the sixth time
I'm forming a government.
And I've been Israel's longest
serving prime minister,
and I describe my
travails and triumphs
in the course of that
very long career.
Within a year, I'll be the
longest serving elected leader
of a democracy in
over half a century
of any place in the world.
But somebody put me
a note the other day,
gave me a note,
and he said, "Well,
you should know that
there are leaders
who've come back from
political death."
Churchill, one example.
Yitzhak Rabin in
Israel is another one.
But this fellow told
me, "I've checked
when was the last time
somebody came back
from political death twice?"
And he said, "That happened
3/4 of a century ago."
So I don't belittle
the task before me,
but I think after a succession
of indecisive elections
in the formation of
a peculiar government
that was brought
down after a year,
we now have a solid
majority, a coherent majority
to form a center right
and right government,
coherent in policy
that will, I think, take
Israel and the Middle East
to fantastic places, contrary
to the left-leaning press.
Will get more peace treaties,
perhaps end the Arab-Israeli
conflict altogether.
Not the Palestinian-Israeli
conflict,
the conflict with
the Arab world,
which is 99 times the
size of the Palestinians.
And block Iran, and
develop technologies
that will stupefy the world
and service all of humanity.
These are some of the
goals that I have,
and I think they're
within reach.
Yes, I think it'll
be more stable
and I think it'll be successful.
- You mention a center
right or right coalition.
Can you sort of compare
how that's different
than, say, an American right?
I know you're a student of
American politics as well,
but for you guys, the right
is, it's a little bit different
just by the nature
of the demographics
and everything else.
- Well, I think
the, first of all,
it's a parliamentary system.
So you have to cobble
together a coalition.
It's not as if the prime
minister is elected
by popular vote
like the president
and he can choose his
cabinet and so on.
This is not the way--
- Do you get jealous
of our two party system
when you're in the midst
of trying to cobble
this thing together?
- Wildly so.
Envious to the
roots of my being.
Because cobbling together
a coalition is like,
you're familiar
with a Rubik's Cube,
you know?
- Yeah, of course.
- Turn one and then
you have to turn the
other one and it matches,
and you turn, and
you think you got it,
and then the last
piece doesn't match,
you have to start
all over again?
That's more or less
what I've been doing
over the last few weeks,
but I think I'm getting there.
This is not Rubin's Cube,
this is Rubik's Cube.
(Dave laughs)
And I'm Rubik.
So at the end, I have to be
Rubik or there's no government.
There will be a government.
So the first thing is
you have to cobble
together a coalition,
that is a majority in the
members of the parliament
or congress, if you will,
and they choose
the prime minister.
And obviously if we put it
together, they'll choose me.
That's the first change.
The second change is you have
a multiplicity of parties.
You don't have two parties,
you have, I don't know,
12 parties in the Knesset,
something like that.
And the third thing is that
the right in Israel is
first of all premised,
the differences
between left and right
are premised first of all in
the intensity that you put
on the question of security.
Security is the number one
issue in Israeli elections.
The economy is a second.
Sometimes a distance second.
I would say the intensity
of identification
with the Jewish state
and how you protect it
is really what guides
Israeli elections,
and that's what brought
me to office here,
because the outgoing government,
to cobble together
their coalition,
basically made a pact with
a party, an Arab party,
that identifies with
the Muslim Brotherhood.
The Muslim brotherhood who
won't recognize the Jewish state
and wants to dissolve
the Jewish state.
Now obviously the
outgoing coalition
didn't wanna dissolve
the Jewish state,
but they made themselves
hostage to a party that does
in order to stay in power.
Well, that didn't last long
and it was brought down,
and now I assure you,
that's not gonna be repeated.
By the way, many
Arabs support me.
Many Arabs vote for the Likud.
Arabs have served in the Likud,
and can serve in any
government in the future.
But the issue is not the
ethnicity of the voters,
or the ministers, or
the Knesset members,
it's their ideology.
And once the ideology,
to which unfortunately
some Jews subscribe, too,
Jewish Knesset members,
that Israel should be dissolved,
destroyed, eliminated,
obviously that didn't
do well with the voters,
so here we are, we have
a way to correct this.
- How do you balance
some of the tensions
between the secular people
and the more religious people
as someone that's gonna be
prime minister for everybody?
You've obviously done this
a couple times before,
obviously very successfully.
But that that's one of
the sort of fissures
in Israeli society.
- What you do in any
democracy is you compromise.
You make compromises.
There are things you
don't compromise about.
On Israel's existence, on
security, I don't compromise.
And if I have to stand up
and go to a joint
session of Congress
to challenge a person I
respected, but disagreed with,
President Obama, he wanted to
pass this, and did actually,
this dangerous
Iran nuclear deal,
which would pave Iran's path
with gold to a nuclear arsenal.
Well, I thought,
I have no choice,
I have to go and take a stand
and gave a speech there,
which I describe in detail.
So there are things you
don't compromise about.
But in political
life in democracies,
that's what you constantly do.
You either come to an
agreement with opposing views,
and if you don't
come to an agreement,
you bring it to a vote.
And often you come
to an agreement
by arriving at some kind of
balance between opposing views,
and that's being done every day.
You do it in the
American Congress,
you do it in the
Israeli Knesset.
- So as someone that's,
you're basically the
same age as the country,
within a couple years, and
you were born in a time
when the country was
trying to come together,
was obviously not powerful,
it was a couple miracles
basically to even come
into existence as a nation,
versus now where
there's a military might
and an economic power
that you're talking about.
How different is that
for the Israeli psyche,
or even just for you as
the leader of the country,
knowing what the
country was 50 years ago
compared to where
it's at in 2022?
- Well, I described
the roots of my views,
and it's very much
influenced by my father,
who was a great historian
of the Jewish people.
But what he taught me was that
there is no finality
in the life of nations.
Nations have come and
nations have gone,
and the Jewish people are
perhaps unique in the fact
that having lost our country,
having lost our state,
having been dispersed to the
far corners of the earth,
we actually came back and
reconstituted our national life
in our home, in our tiny
homeland, but our homeland.
And the fact that
we did that was,
I would say the mission of
restoring Jewish nationhood
and Jewish independence
in the land of Israel
was the task that
informed my grandfather
and my father in founding
and helping found the state.
The task that I inherited
was to secure the future,
the prosperity and especially
the security and permanence
of this state, because
it's not guaranteed.
Well, what guarantees,
the life of states
in a turbulent world,
which is often cruel?
Well, for some
people on the left,
they think that if you're moral
and if you put up a nice
facade to the world,
a compliant facade, then
history will protect you.
In fact, they often
quote Martin Luther King
who said that "The arc of
history bends towards justice."
Maybe so, but it is
a very brittle arc
and it could break under the
pounding of the darkest forces,
the totalitarian and dictatorial
and ideological forces
that are opposed to the very
idea of freedom and justice.
And history doesn't favor
morality, it favors strength.
That's what it does.
That's why Genghis Khan
could conquer the world
and hold on, that empire
could hold on for a century.
Through enormous
subjugation, the Romans,
whatever you think of them,
held it for many,
many more centuries
through just sheer power,
sheer cohesion and power.
And does it guarantee that
our free civilization,
does history guarantee
that our free civilization
will triumph over
totalitarian forces?
And the answer is
categorically not.
If they can amass
greater economic,
military, and political power,
especially economic
and military power,
then they'll overcome you
if you don't have enough
countervailing force.
Israel, being a tiny country,
had to be enormously
more powerful
given that it was
surrounded at first
by hundreds of millions of
Arabs who wanted to destroy it,
and lately by about a
hundred million Iranians
who don't want to destroy it,
but are governed by these
theological thugs who do
and openly declare
death to Israel,
and by the way,
death to America too,
but they're building
atomic bombs,
or that's what they seek
to do, to destroy Israel.
So you need to be
very, very strong.
I devoted my life, as
I describe in my book,
to empower Israel,
not to subjugate others,
but to defend itself from others
and to make sure that
nobody could destroy
the one and only Jewish state
once it was reconstituted
after thousands of years.
The one thing that,
and all Israelis
understood that.
They understood that we
have to have a strong army.
The first prime minister,
David Ben-Gurion,
invested an enormous effort
to build such an army.
But I came to the conclusion
that it couldn't be sustained.
It couldn't be sustained
because F-35 fighter aircraft,
submarines, drones, cyber
intelligence and so on,
they have one common quality:
They cost money, a lot of money.
And if you have a
socialist economy,
you're not gonna be
able to pay for defense.
Typically the way
Israelis thought about it,
well, the government
will produce the money.
How will they produce the
money? Well, tax the rich.
Tax the rich,
well, first of all,
there are not enough rich
people in a socialist economy.
And secondly, those who are
will move to other places
when you overtax them.
I came with a radical idea,
which I describe in my book,
that there's a thing called
free markets capitalism.
And that's the way we generate
both a better life for our
people, a higher income,
a higher distribution of income
compared to what the socialist
leaning people were thinking,
but also it gives us
the wherewithal to
fund our military.
And therefore, I initiated
a free market
revolution in Israel
that made Israel
into this juggernaut,
this free market juggernaut
of the innovation nation
that can compete with
any country in the world,
and in fact does, and
that changed Israel.
It gave it the economic power
to have military power,
and the combination of the
two gave us diplomatic power,
and that is what can
guarantee our future.
Not forever.
I don't know of anything
that protects you forever.
But for the coming decades,
and that's what I intend
to nurture further
in the coming years in my
next tenure as prime minister.
- So I wanna get back
to the economic stuff
because I think it's super
interesting that you guys went,
in essence, from a socialist
nation to a capitalist nation,
and then in economic prowess.
Where in the United States
we seem to be doing some
version of the reverse of that,
at least at the moment,
hopefully not for too long.
But on some of the security
stuff you just mentioned,
you were sort of way ahead
when it came to
the Gaza withdrawal
of 20 some odd years ago.
You were not for it
when Sharon did it,
and you said it would
not bring peace.
Clearly that was proven correct.
When you talk to your
lefty counterparts,
or if they're willing
to talk to you,
do they still believe that, oh,
if we just give away enough land
that actually that
would provide peace?
I mean, are there really
thought leaders on the left
that believe those
things at this point?
Or is it just posturing?
- Well, no, I think
some of them believe it,
but they also avoid
talking about it
because most of the
public doesn't accept it.
Why? Because we tried it.
So we left, we vacated Lebanon.
The argument was you give
territory, you get peace.
Territory for peace.
Okay, we left Lebanon
and that territory
was taken over
by proxies of Iran, Hezbollah,
who fired 10,000 rockets
since then into Israel.
We left Gaza,
again with the hope that
this would create peace,
and this was taken over
by another proxy of Iran,
or a close ally of Iran, Hamas,
and they fired 10,000
rockets into Israel.
And if you say, all right, so
let's leave Judea, Samaria,
which is the heartland, the
biblical heartland of Israel
and envelopes Jerusalem
and is within spitting distance
of Tel Aviv, just leave.
And Israel, by the way,
would become 10 miles wide
with its back.
And just shut your
eyes, hope for the best,
and hope that what happened
in Lebanon with Hezbollah,
what happened in Gaza with Hamas
doesn't recur in Judea,
Samara, the West Bank, okay?
People can't buy that now,
because we've tried it.
You know, fool me
once, shame on me.
Fool me twice, you know that.
People are not gonna do that.
So you ask, do they believe it?
They probably cling
to it as a religious,
sort of a religious,
quasi-religious belief
that they don't
(indistinct) right away,
but politically, this
simply didn't come up
in the previous elections,
it just wasn't an issue.
Not at all.
And you know, the issue
was me. I was the issue.
They basically said, the issue
wasn't Israel's security,
not the idea of creating
a Palestinian state,
which would be an
armed Palestinian state
committed to our destruction.
People didn't buy that.
- Right, it would also be
two states, wouldn't it?
Wouldn't, in essence,
there would be two.
I mean, it would really
be a three-state solution,
not a two-state solution,
because Gaza and the West Bank
obviously are not connected.
People don't seem to
really understand that.
- Gaza's already
been thrown away,
and it's effectively
an independent state
surrounded by Israel and Egypt,
but it's an independent state.
Well, what do they do with it?
You know, they build
tunnels, terror tunnels,
in order to penetrate
us, or build rockets.
They don't do a thing for
their people, the Hamas.
You know, they execute.
That's what they do.
They shoot them in
the back of the neck
if they dare utter a dissent.
They abuse their women,
they abuse gays and so on,
but that doesn't prevent
the international left
from talking about human rights,
talking about Israel
and human rights,
and not about these thugs
who do these horrible
things to their own people,
just as until recently they
didn't talk about Iran,
until those brave,
extraordinarily brave women
went out in the street,
and this created
a united front of left and right
that finally sees
the true nature
of this horrible
regime in Tehran.
That hasn't yet happened
to the Palestinians,
but you can look,
what do you think
is the difference
between the Iranian regime
and the Palestinian
regime in Gaza?
The answer is nothing.
It's only smaller.
And less well armed,
that's the only difference.
But in terms of violating
the rights of Palestinians,
and men and women
and everybody else,
they're horrible,
horrible people.
So you can't get peace,
if you talk about peace.
The reason we haven't had
peace with the Palestinians
is because the Palestinians
don't want peace.
I mean, they've
been led by leaders
who are committed to
Israel's destruction
for now for a century, before
the existence of Israel
and since the
existence of Israel.
And they say they want
peace, but without Israel.
They say they want a state,
but it's not a state
next to Israel,
it's a state instead of Israel.
So one of the
things that happened
as a result of what I just
described is that people said,
you have to first have
peace with the Palestinians
before we can have peace
with the broader Arab world.
Remember, the Palestinians are
one to 2% of the Arab world,
both in land mass
and in population.
But the regnant thinking,
the prevailing thinking
in the foreign policy
elites (chuckles)
in the foreign ministry
chancelleries of the world,
you have to have peace
with the Palestinians
or you won't have
peace between Israel
and the rest of the Arab world.
And I thought--
- And you did it the other way.
- Not only did I do
it the other way,
we waited for 25 years,
a quarter of a century,
that way we didn't get
anywhere, we couldn't,
and we'd wait another half
century, maybe another century.
I said, no, we're going around,
we're going around that,
and we'll go directly
to the Arab world.
And as a result of the
rise of Israeli power,
because of the revolution
that we led, I led
to make Israel a
free market economy,
which bolstered our
military and intel
and cyber capability,
we became very valuable
to other countries,
valuable in civilian technology,
which could better the
lives of their citizens,
and valuable in terms of
offering security help,
of fending off a common
threat like Iran.
So what happened was, and
I could see this happening
and I nurtured it to happen,
is that Arab states began to
look at us not as an enemy,
but as their indispensable ally
in fending off
Iranian aggression,
which would subjugate them too,
and bringing a better
life for their citizens.
And that view was, I
would say was dramatized,
brought to a head in that
speech that I made in Congress
challenging President
Obama's deal with Iran.
While I was giving that
speech, in real time,
we got phone calls
from Gulf states
in which the representatives
of these governments
were saying, "We can't believe
what your prime
minister is doing.
We can't believe he's
standing up the way he is,
because he's really
standing up for us.
We don't have the
gumption to do that."
But that led to
clandestine meetings.
I'm talking about 2015.
2015.
That led to secret meetings
with the Gulf leaders,
and that laid the foundation
for the Abraham Accords
that turned things upside down.
If the idea was that you
make peace inside out
from the Palestinians to
the broader Arab world,
I said, well, maybe so if the
Palestinians want to come,
but we're not gonna
wait for them.
And I said, we're gonna
make an inside outside in.
We'll go to the Arab states,
and finally, we'll double
back to the Palestinians.
That produced four
historic peace accords
with the help of President
Trump and his team.
The Abraham Accords.
Peace with the United Arab
Emirates, peace with Bahrain,
peace with Morocco,
and peace with Sudan,
and I've actually
come to this podcast,
to this discussion of ours
right from the celebrating
the Independence Day of the
Emirates here in Tel Aviv.
If you'd said two years ago--
- Yeah.
- You know, (chuckles)
if you said two years
ago this would happen,
people would think you're crazy.
I didn't think it was crazy,
I knew it would happen.
If you told me that hundreds
of thousands of Israelis
would be flying over the
skies of Saudi Arabia
and dancing in the
streets with the Emiratis
in Abu Dhabi and in Dubai,
you'd say, this is crazy,
but it's not crazy,
it's happening.
And this is the path to
peace that I intend to pursue
with much greater,
even greater fervor.
Not much greater fervor,
but greater fervor,
and great opportunity
in the coming year.
- How much of the (speaks
in foreign language),
there's a word for you,
of the Middle East,
is just people not really
understanding the history?
I've heard you talk about
the history of Israel
many, many times,
but people not understanding
that when you talk
about Judea and Samaria,
which we now know
as the West Bank.
Judea, Jews used to live there.
Bethlehem, that's
where Jesus lived.
That this is not a place
that Jews are foreign from,
that people simply
don't understand
the basic history of the land.
- Well, you know,
in the modern world,
you're lucky if your
historical memory
goes back to breakfast.
That's pretty good.
- Yeah.
- But in our case,
I mean, people,
you're right, they
don't know the facts.
They think we're the
Belgians in the Congo,
or the Dutch in Indonesia,
or some British colonials,
I don't know, in some other
part of Africa and so on.
And of course this
is not the case.
As you say, Jews
came from Judea.
King David. It's been our
homeland for 3,500 years.
3,000 years ago,
King David proclaimed
Jerusalem as our capital.
The events described
in the Bible
occurred for a period of about
2,000 years, actually less,
but about 1,500 years
until the birth of,
just before the birth
of Christianity.
Now, where did that happen?
Where did Jesus turn over the
tables of the money changers?
It wasn't in a temple
in Tibet, you know.
Didn't happen next to
Joburg in South Africa.
It happened right
there in Jerusalem.
And what language
did Jesus speak?
He spoke Hebrew, and
he spoke Aramaic,
he probably wrote
in Hebrew and so on.
His name is a Hebrew name.
He was a Jewish rabbi
from the Galilee.
So there's an attempt to erase
the first roughly 2,000
years of Jewish history.
It didn't exist. The
Jews were not there.
Well, we were the original
natives of the land,
and actually we
were dispossessed.
You know, all these conquerors,
people who conquered us,
the Romans, and before
them the Greeks,
and after them the
Byzantines and so on,
none of them displaced us.
Actually, the displacement of
the Jews from their homeland
took place in greater numbers
and in significant numbers
after the Arabs conquered the
land in the seventh century,
okay, so it's not, the
Arabs were the ones
who expropriated the
land from the Jews,
and the Jews didn't
expropriate it from the Arabs.
Well, that happens.
So what, you're gonna go back
now 1,300 years to
the seventh century,
the Arabs came in, they
live there, it's their land.
No, that's not what happened.
The Arab conquest didn't
populate the land.
They didn't build new
cities except one,
communities, one,
one called Rama.
Everything else was left barren.
And they, too, were displaced
by other conquerors.
Mongols, the Ottomans,
the British at the end.
I won't get into that.
But a succession of
empires governed this land.
And it was nothing,
it wasn't the homeland
of anyone except the Jews
who never gave up the dream
of coming back to there,
and over the centuries
Jews would pray,
"Next year in Jerusalem,
next year in Jerusalem."
It was only in the 19th century
when a modern Moses
emerged for our people.
His name was Theodore Herzl.
He was 36 years old and he
worked only for eight years.
That's it, for eight years.
Giant of history.
Because he died young at 44.
And he said the only way
to have national salvation
and to avoid what he foresaw
would be the Holocaust in Europe
would be for the Jewish
people to come back
to their ancestral homeland.
That return that began
in the latter part
of the 19th century
brought the land back to life.
And as we were bringing
it back to life,
there were people living
there, but very few.
But there was a great
influx that came in
as a result of
the Jewish return,
influx of Arabs who came
in for better wages,
for the factories,
for the hospitals,
for the farms that
the Jews built.
That attracted many Arabs.
They now call
themselves Palestinians.
They say, "We've been here
for thousands of years,"
you know, from
the time of Jesus.
No, they weren't.
We had a verdant homeland
when the Jews came here
in the 19th century.
No you didn't.
Mark Twain will attest to
that, and hundreds of--
- (laughs) Yeah.
- Nothing. You
had nothing there.
We came back to our ancestral
homeland, rebuilt it,
accepted our Arab neighbors.
But they refused to have
us, and they still refuse.
So if you want to understand
the justice of the Jewish case,
is we never gave up our
claim to our homeland.
We are the native
owners of the land.
We are the ones who have
every right to live there
having been dispossessed from
it, first of all by Arabs,
but we don't want to dispossess
the Arabs themselves.
They're the ones
who refuse to do it.
And if you ask me, what
is the persistent obstacle
to having an
Israeli-Palestinian peace
as opposed to an Israeli-Arab
peace, which we're achieving,
it's the persistent
Palestinian refusal
to recognize a Jewish
state in any boundary.
That's the problem.
And because that's not gonna
be resolved right away,
I say, go to the Arab world,
get these extraordinary
agreements with
the Arab countries,
and the greatest prize would be,
without a doubt, Saudi Arabia,
which would effectively,
peace with Saudi Arabia
would effectively end
the Arab-Israeli conflict.
And then do your damnedest
to get the
rejectionist leadership
in the Palestinian world,
Palestinian society
to accept the right
of the Jewish people
to have a state of their own,
then I think we
can have a solution
to the Israeli-Palestinian
conflict.
But I think that's
gonna be the order.
I had to change a perception
that had been ingrained
in the minds of the experts
and the foreign mavens,
and you name them, for
close to half a century.
I'd simply challenged
it and I was--
- The think tank people in DC
probably were not that
thrilled with you.
- Well, the think tank
people in Tel Aviv
weren't thrilled with the idea.
Basically, you
know, I have an idea
that all think tanks
and many diplomats
are all produced
in a secret plant,
30 kilometers west
of Luxembourg,
and then they're sort
of sent, dispatched
to all the bureaucracies,
the foreign policy
bureaucracies of the world,
and they just chant this thing.
The Palestinian conflict
is the core of the conflict,
always in the singular,
in the Middle East.
No, it's not.
The only way that
you can solve it
is for Israel to become so weak
that it couldn't defend itself.
No, it's not.
There's not gonna be peace
with the rest of the Arab world
if you don't solve the
Palestinian-Israeli conflict.
No, it's not.
But you know, if
you invest yourself
in this nonsense for decades,
it's very hard to
detach yourself from it.
And so I--
- I always find it interesting
how it sort of mainstreams
itself in a bizarre sense.
So for example,
you know Rashida Tlaib, our
congresswoman in Michigan,
who I have no doubt
you're not a big fan of,
I think maybe she was even
banned from Israel at one point,
every December she wishes
Jews a happy Hanukkah.
But at the same time,
she doesn't want Jews
living in the place
that is the story of Hanukkah.
Does she know about the hills,
probably about two miles
from you right now?
- Happy Hanukkah.
You know, Hanukkah
celebrated the victory
of the brave Maccabees
against one of the
conquerors of our land
actually 2,200 years ago,
roughly 2,200 years ago.
2,200 years ago.
Jews were fighting
for their freedom
against basically
the Seleucid Empire,
which was based in Syria.
It's named after one of the
generals of Alexander the Great,
who actually had a positive
attitude towards Jews
but his inheritors didn't,
and one of them wanted to
wipe out the Jewish religion,
and Jews rebelled.
And this rebellion
led by brothers,
who each died, they all
died in this battle,
finally achieved the
liberation of the land
and the liberation of Jerusalem.
That's what we celebrate.
Hanukkah is the
liberation of Jerusalem,
specifically the cleansing
of the Jewish temple.
So tell that to Rashida Tlaib,
I wanna hear a response.
So were the Jews there or not?
Were the Palestinians
there in Hanukkah,
or the Jews were
there in Hanukkah?
And this exemplifies
the tremendous ignorance
that you discuss,
they just don't know.
The Jews, the Jewish people,
are probably one of the
oldest civilizations,
or not probably, are
one of the two or three
oldest civilizations in history.
Our attachment to our ancestral
homeland is unmatched.
A lot of people are attached
to their ancestral homeland,
but they're not as old as us.
And a lot of them lost
their ancestral homeland
and disappeared.
We're the only ones who
were kicked out of it,
expelled from it, and said,
"We're gonna come back."
And we came back, defying
the odds of history,
achieved this miracle,
built this extraordinarily
modern, successful state.
We respect our roots, we
respect our neighbors,
and we are bringing a
light unto the nations,
principally by
incredible technology.
And yet they say, you have no
right to live there, you know.
We kicked you out once,
we'll kick you out again.
No, you won't. It won't happen.
Whether you are Hamas
or Hezbollah or Iran,
it's not gonna happen.
We're not gonna let it happen.
- Well, it certainly ain't
gonna happen under your watch.
I do wanna be
respectful of your time
because it's late night
in Israel right now,
and you are in the midst
of this coalition build
that I'm sure you have
some things to do.
I wanna ask you just
one thing personally,
and I'll post the
link to the book
and people can read
all about your history,
and your brother,
and there's really some
remarkable stuff in there.
But just on a
personal note to end,
you've had to go into
the fire a million times,
not only in the military,
but in terms of going to the UN,
giving these speeches, the
hostility towards Israel,
standing up for your country,
and your beliefs, and your
religion, all of those things.
It can't be easy, it
can't be that fun.
I mean, the amount
of hate and protests
and all of this stuff.
And I wonder, at your age,
coming back, doing this again,
it's not the easiest
thing in the world,
but you're doing it again and
you seem as energized as ever,
and where does that
come from within you?
And did you think
about not doing it?
I mean, when the last
election didn't go your way
did you think, "Okay,
let me just step away,"
or you were basically fighting
in the opposition immediately?
- Well, there was one incident
that I describe in
one of my defeats,
because I've had a few defeats.
I've had a succession of
victories, but also had defeats,
and that question arose.
I had one elections where my
party contracted to 12 seats.
That's 10% of the Knesset.
For comparison, we
now have 32 seats
in a coalition of 64 out of 120,
32 led by my party,
which is by far the largest
party in the Knesset.
A quarter of the seats,
more than a quarter.
And a coalition that is solid.
But here you get, this happened
where I contracted to 12 seats,
and I came back from
meeting the party faithful,
there weren't too many in
that evening of defeat.
And I said to my
wife, Sarah, I said,
"Look, you know,
maybe this is the end.
They eulogize me all the time.
Maybe this time they're right.
Why don't we just
get on with our family,
with our two young boys,
and with our life, and
get on with our life."
And she said to me,
"Bibi, this is your life.
Don't leave it. This
is your purpose."
And if you ask
what has guided me,
what allows me to do this,
it's this sense of purpose.
It's the fact that I'm
pursuing a mission,
and the mission which I
inherited from my grandfather
and my father and my
fallen brother is to assure
the security and permanence
of the state of Israel,
only by making it
strong and powerful.
But I think it's not only
my family and my wife and kids,
two boys, who support me
and who share this mission,
otherwise it would be
impossible to continue,
but it's also millions
and millions of people.
Not only millions
of people in Israel,
millions of Jews
throughout the world,
but millions of non-Jews who
see in the story of Israel
a parable for humanity.
Because if the Jewish people
can overcome the most
dreadful odds in history,
can come back from the dead,
can ford this river between
annihilation and salvation
and build this remarkable state,
then there's hope
for all of humanity.
And alongside the
defamation of Israel,
the slander, the vilification,
I have to say there's
enormous, enormous respect
and admiration and
sometimes adoration
in many, many lands.
And as Israel emerges
as one of these rising
powers in the world,
able to send aid missions,
emergency missions to dozens
and dozens of countries,
some of them hostile countries,
to help people out
of earthquakes, or
hurricanes, or floods,
and people see the true
nature of this state,
and when they pick up their
cell phone and they understand
that a good part of that
technology in that cell phone
that makes their life
different completely
comes from Israel,
or when you navigate
in your car with Waze,
another Israeli product,
and it's endless,
it goes on and on.
The medicine, the technology,
the health, the
water desalinization,
all these things that
are not pie in the sky,
they're not, this is real.
It's changing the life,
not only of Israelis,
but of the world.
Then there is also a different
admiration for Israel.
The life of purpose
that I'm talking about
says that the Jewish people
have come back from the dead,
and we are here, and we
will continue to hold
the high ground, literally
and figuratively.
We are here and we're here
to stay. That's my purpose.
And I would say to those people
who wanna read my
book, my story,
it's not really my story alone.
It is my years in
an combat unit,
I nearly died several
times in fire fights.
I describe most of it
within the limits
of military propriety.
And I nearly died
twice politically.
But it's not merely my life,
it's interwoven with the
life of the Jewish people
and the Jewish state.
But I think that there
is a larger issue here.
I live, and I can say
this categorically,
a life of purpose.
If you have a
purpose in your life,
and preferably if it
goes beyond yourself,
it will enrich your life
and make it meaningful.
It's the only life worth living.
And if you want to glean
some insights about that,
then unabashedly, I tell you,
I'm plugging my
book, read my book.
I think they'll benefit from it.
- Well, we will link
down to your book below,
Mr. Prime Minister.
Cards on the table, it's
fairly obvious to me
why the Israeli
people are giving you
another crack at this,
and I suspect some
other peace deals
and other good things
are gonna come.
And I have to say that I
will be in Israel in May
doing a few events,
and you did break bread
with my good friends
Jordan Peterson and Ben
Shapiro not too long ago,
so maybe I can take you out for
hummus, something like that?
- Got it. (chuckles)
Let's do it.
Maybe I can take you out. The
Israeli economy is doing well.
- (laughs) It would
be an honor, sir.
The book is "Bibi: My Story".
The link is right down below.
and I appreciate it,
Mr. Prime Minister.
Now go do your coalition thing.
- I'm doing exactly that.
You think I'm joking,
but that's exactly what I'm
doing in the other room.
- (laughs) Thank you so much.
Really, truly an honor, sir.
- Thank you.
- If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful conversations
about international issues
instead of non-stop yelling,
check out our
international playlist.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, check
out our full episode playlist.
They're all right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.